[Music]
senior workers found the body in the
pipe
[Music]
all right here we go and action
a young woman called julia madrigal
it was six years ago
i was cut up like julia that's someone
did you junior they tried it into you
after what he did
[Music]
everything changed
kirby masrachi is six years post a very
traumatic incident where she was
attacked and she survived
she's living with trauma and it's
controlling her life
when we first meet kirby we see her
writing in her diary and she's writing
down the most basic things her address
what the name of her cat is where she
works what her desk looks like
what told this i take notes same as you
these are basic facts that you already
know when i got out of the hospital
everything was different
you don't really know why this is
happening
for me the stuff that really makes the
show tick is the day-to-day trying to
keep control of your life that keeps
falling out of control i think a lot of
people can relate to that she's trying
to figure out why her world keeps
changing and how it's connected to her
attacker in pursuing that we also meet a
journalist investigating the story a
survivor hunting a serial killer that's
your story
dan velasquez is investigating at the
chicago sun times little by little they
both
tracked his killer
he moved around he kept his distance he
didn't though he got close he knew all
about us
the shining girls are the women that he
has chosen over the years
to kill
they have potential they have a life
ahead of them they have this i'm gonna
go make something of myself and that is
incredibly threatening
and that's what he has to take away
his reba don't know each other he is the
one connecting them these actors jamie
vogg pippa
all turned in these performances that
were super different from anything
they've ever done before i love being
involved in something that manages to
tell a very difficult story about
trauma and violence against women
there is this fantastical element to it
but there's also a likeness to it and
there's a hope to it the people who like
the show are fans of great thrillers
they are fans who like strong female
characters great drama and great
performances it's an entertainment show
with something to say while i hope
audiences are carried away with a
mystery i hope they connect with kirby's
story and her strengths
[Music]
you